here's the thing about james dahlin
he wants to play music
and being the son of a billionaire
and inheriting a bunch of were of money
and a bunch of responsibility
is a a big burden he doesn't want to do
this job
he wants to play music he should sell
now the market could
couldn't possibly be at a bigger peak he
can get a ton of money for it
and you know what god bless go
play the blues when you see him playing
the blues
he is smiling i saw him play
go find a church with jewel and a bunch
of other people
now people it's easy to make fun of
somebody you know who's not a
professional musician and who's a trust
fund kid
but he's got pure joy and then i see him
sitting at the
garden and he looks utterly
depressed and sad there's a message to
james stolen
pursue your life's work which is singing
the goddamn blues and you love it
i see it on your face and you know what
he loves to go to a club of 10 people or
20 people and just play the blues
there's a video of him online where
somebody was yelling at him sell the
knicks while he's
playing some music festival he's playing
a music festival in the afternoon
with 20 people in front of a stage and
he is loving it
he's a billionaire he owns the knicks
the rangers radio city musical the
beacon
he's not happy about that he's happy
being
the opening act to the five other
opening acts
and he's humble and in pure ecstasy do
that
james do that jim sell the next to me
give me the goddamn next just give them
to me please
just give me them nicks let me do it
i will get it done i promise you i'll
get it done and i will give you all the
credit in the world
for having the foresight to pick me
that's the next owner of the new york
knickerbockers
thank you james dolan what's more steve
what's your dream what's your dream pop
giants the giants yeah yeah yeah
come on you know my dad's to season
tickets and i used to go
to phil simms at phil sims uh
and uh lawrence taylor i was at all
those games
i watched lawrence taylor he'd come out
of that halftime
he'd done three or four lines of blow
and he would just
run through the air he would run through
the line and just he'd get two or three
sacks in a game
you sat there watching it and phil sims
was just like
we would just be doing the like prevent
defense we would run the ball
they would never let phil sims throw it
but we won
we won the underdogs won and man you
watch lawrence taylor oh my lord
that was like watching an alien
like it was literally like watching a
predator playing with a bunch of humans
you know the predator of the movie i've
watched my daughters feel like eight
feet tall
imagine you had a predator in the middle
of a football game what would happen
that was what lawrence taylor did has
anybody ever done anything equivalent to
what he did
in terms of sacking people and just
being so
incredibly intimidating
probably not the only person i could
think of a different position
but uh maybe like a sean taylor if he
had gotten to play a little more
but other than that i mean there's just
not that many people that just broke
that guy's leg
remember that oh yeah
i mean when has anybody ever gotten
sacked and broken their leg
is that the only time that's ever
happened in the in the history of the
nfl i gotta think it is